Buonasera, noi siamo qui per questo terzo incontro che attraverso delle famose battaglie cerca di spiegare non soltanto come funzionavano strategie e tattiche militari, ma anche gli enormi sforzi che governi e società facevano per mettere in campo gli eserciti e le flotte.
La battaglia di cui parliamo stasera è una battaglia famosissima, anche se probabilmente non siamo d'accordo su come pronunciarne il nome, io tendo a dire Waterloo come sta scritto, che non è neanche tanto diverso da come lo pronunciano i fiamminghi.
E' l'ultima battaglia di Napoleone, è la battaglia che mette fine ai cento giorni, alla breve speranza di Napoleone di ritornare al potere dopo la sua sconfitta del 1814 e dopo il suo esilio all'isola d'Elba.
Siamo nel 1815, a marzo Napoleone è scappato dall'isola d'Elba, è tornato in Francia con pochissime forze ed è successo una specie di miracolo, è successo che gran parte del paese e quasi tutto l'esercito lo ha acclamato come il legittimo sovrano della Francia.
Il re di Francia, Luigi XVIII di Borbone, rimesso sul trono dalle potenze alleate, fugge, Napoleone arriva a Parigi, riprende il potere, rimette in piedi fulminiamente il suo stato, il suo governo imperiale,
trova anche il tempo di far approvare una nuova Costituzione in cui promette spazi di parlamentarismo liberale, anziché un governo monarchico quasi assoluto come aveva praticato in passato,
e scrive a tutti i sovrani europei per dire che lui vuole la pace.
E' tornato ma non chiede niente, si accontenta della Francia nei confini ridimensionati dal congresso di Vienna, non ha nessuna rivendicazione, vuole soltanto regnare pacificamente.
Fatto sta che non gli credono.
Le sue lettere qualcuno non le apre neanche, al re d'Inghilterra il primo ministro non permette neanche di aprirla, gliela fa rispedire, ancora sigillata,
e immediatamente le potenze che negli anni precedenti si erano coalizzate contro di lui, tornano a stringere un patto di alleanza per invadere la Francia e cacciare Napoleone una volta per tutte.
Quindi questa per una volta è una guerra difensiva, è una delle pochissime guerre difensive che Napoleone combatte nel corso della sua carriera.
Le potenze coalizzate contro di lui sono praticamente tutta Europa.
Ci sono quattro grandi eserciti che si preparano a invadere la Francia.
Uno molto vicino, quello che gli inglesi hanno già pronto in Belgio e in Olanda, e a cui si uniscono contingenti appunto belgi e olandesi e di vari stati tedeschi, al comando del duca di Wellington.
Quello prussiano, la Prussia è la principale potenza tedesca, che è già pronto praticamente sul Reno, deve soltanto avvicinarsi.
Quello austriaco che è già più lontano, quello russo che è molto più lontano, come capite.
Ognuno di questi eserciti preso da solo è più debole dell'esercito che Napoleone è in grado di mettere in campo, ma già due sono più forti, tutti e quattro insieme non ci sarebbe storia.
Napoleone decide che l'unica cosa da fare è agire e agire fulmineamente.
I russi sono molto molto lontani, gli austriaci anche.
Ci sono due eserciti che sono già pronti sui confini della Francia e stanno aspettando che arrivino anche gli altri per iniziare l'invasione.
E sono appunto l'esercito inglese e olandese e tedesco al comando di Wellington e l'esercito prussiano al comando di Blücher.
Questi due eserciti sono accantonati, come si diceva allora, in tutto il territorio del Belgio.
Il Belgio e l'Olanda formano un'unica monarchia sotto la Casa d'Orange in quel momento, alleata della coalizione.
Dunque sono in paese amico, sono accantonati come si usava allora, in un'epoca in cui quasi non esistevano le caserme, o comunque si usavano pochissimo.
E per mantenere un esercito si piazzavano, si collocavano i soldati a casa dei contadini e gli ufficiali a casa dei borghesi e dei nobili.
E era un obbligo civico ospitare e mantenere questa gente.
Questo significa naturalmente, lo capite, che questi eserciti sono sparpagliati su tutto il territorio del Belgio.
Perché in ogni villaggio trova posto una compagnia di soldati, se va bene.
Qui ci sono quasi centomila uomini nell'esercito di Wellington, più di centomila in quello prussiano, sono sparpagliati da un angolo all'altro del Belgio.
Napoleone più o meno ha messo insieme centomila uomini, l'Armée du Nord.
È sicuro che se affronta uno di quei due eserciti lo annienterà senza fatica.
Deve impedire che possano reagire, mettersi insieme, affrontarlo insieme su un unico teatro di battaglia.
Di conseguenza Napoleone decide di agire molto rapidamente, di entrare in Belgio prima che il nemico se ne possa accorgere e di travolgere tutto quello che si trova davanti.
Verso la metà di giugno del 1815 Napoleone sigilla le frontiere, dalla Francia per qualche giorno non esce più, non dico una carrozza o un turista, ma neanche una lettera, neanche un giornale.
E in quei pochi giorni l'esercito francese marcia fino alla frontiera e la sera del 15 giugno entra in Belgio.
La notizia arriva fulminamente ai comandi inglesi e prussiani ed è una notizia terrificante perché i loro eserciti sono ancora sparsi, disuniti e i francesi sono lì.
Ma sono tutti dei professionisti, sanno come reagire.
Molto rapidamente sia gli inglesi sia i prussiani cominciano a radunare le loro forze sparse, il più vicino possibile alla frontiera, per cercare di dare battaglia a Napoleone, impedirgli di invadere il Belgio, di conquistare Bruxelles, che sarebbe dal punto di vista, voi lo capite, della propaganda una cosa molto sgradevole per la coalizione se la guerra cominciasse con Napoleone che conquista, cattura una delle capitali dei sovrani nemici.
Dunque bisogna dare battaglia il più avanti possibile.
Napoleone avanza senza bene sapere chi si troverà prima di fronte, con delle forze sulla destra dalla parte dove si aspetta i prussiani, sulla sinistra dove si aspetta gli inglesi, e una forte riserva con la guardia imperiale da buttare sul lato dove ce ne sarà bisogno.
Il 16 giugno c'è battaglia perché i prussiani hanno radunato una parte delle loro forze e gli sbarrano la strada.
Napoleone quindi con la sua ala destra e con tutta la riserva che sposta da quel lato affronta i prussiani in una battaglia che è la battaglia di Ligny, che è l'ultima vittoria di Napoleone.
Napoleone effettivamente sconfigge i prussiani molto duramente, li mette in fuga, dopodiché si sposta dall'altra parte,
dove il duca di Wellington ha radunato frettolosamente quel che ha potuto trovare del suo esercito anglo-olandese-tedesco, un esercito in cui si parlano quattro lingue,
e ha tentato di fermare l'alla sinistra di Napoleone, c'è stato uno scontro, una piccola battaglia che si chiama di Catrebra,
gli inglesi hanno tenuto, però alla sera vengono a sapere che sul loro fianco Napoleone ha sbaragliato i prussiani e sta andando avanti.
Di conseguenza il duca di Wellington non può fare altro che ritirarsi anche lui in direzione di Bruxelles.
Per tutto il giorno 17 l'esercito inglese si ritira sull'unica grande strada verso Bruxelles e l'esercito di Napoleone li insegue.
I prussiani si stanno ritirando altrove, sono stati battuti e Napoleone è convinto che non li vedrà più.
Ha mandato una parte della sua ala destra a inseguirli, ma non si preoccupa.
Lui con l'ala sinistra e la riserva insegue gli inglesi.
Perché gli inglesi si ritirano in realtà?
L'esercito inglese, io dico sempre inglese, bisogna sempre fare uno sforzo per ricordarsi che soltanto un terzo di quelle forze erano davvero inglesi,
gli altri erano olandesi, belgi, tedeschi, il comando era inglese.
L'esercito di Wellington è più o meno grande come quello di Napoleone, sono circa 70.000 uomini per parte,
quelli che si inseguono sulla strada selciata che va a Bruxelles.
E allora perché di questi due eserciti uno si ritira, non osa dare battaglia,
e l'altro, quello francese, lo insegue senza nessuna paura, cercando la battaglia, cercando lo scontro decisivo.
Se uno guarda, appunto, il numero di uomini è più o meno lo stesso.
Napoleone aveva più cannoni, aveva circa 250 cannoni contro un 150 di Wellington,
e questo per un motivo molto preciso.
Napoleone era un vecchio sottotenente di artiglieria,
che in artiglieria aveva fatto i suoi primi passi,
e che sapeva molto bene quanto contano i cannoni,
e che aveva sempre speso per avere più cannoni degli altri,
aveva sempre investito in cannoni,
perché anche queste cose poi nelle battaglie vengono fuori.
Gli eserciti sono come li hanno fatti i governi,
e i governi li hanno fatti in base alle idee che avevano su come deve essere un esercito,
e in base ai soldi che avevano da spendere.
I soldi sono un limite molto grosso.
Per esempio la cavalleria di Napoleone, in questi giorni, in questi giorni di Waterloo,
è più debole del solito,
perché non ha avuto abbastanza soldi per comprare cavalli buoni.
I suoi famosi corazzieri sono montati in gran parte su cavalli scadenti,
perché non c'erano fondi per trovare, per comprare cavalli adatti.
Ma allora perché comunque l'esercito inglese si ritira?
Solo perché ha meno cannoni?
In realtà no.
Guardiamo un po' come sono fatti questi eserciti.
Come si facevano gli eserciti in quell'epoca?
Chi è che prestava servizio?
Siamo dopo la rivoluzione francese, naturalmente.
Siamo dopo che è stato abbattuto l'antico regime,
che è stato abbattuto un po' in tutta Europa,
tranne in Inghilterra, ricordiamocelo,
perché l'Inghilterra, che da un certo punto di vista è il paese più moderno del mondo in quell'epoca,
l'Inghilterra sta facendo la rivoluzione industriale in quel momento,
però da un altro punto di vista l'Inghilterra è il paese più arcaico d'Europa,
è l'unico dove non è arrivata la rivoluzione francese,
è ancora un paese di antico regime,
e il suo esercito è un esercito di antico regime,
come quello dei vecchi re di una volta, del re sole,
è fatto di mercenari in pratica,
è fatto cioè di gente che fa il soldato di mestiere,
non sono mercenari stranieri, sono sudditi britannici,
ma sono gente che fa il soldato di mestiere,
che si arruola, che firma un contratto che obbliga a servire per un gran numero di anni,
in cambio di una paga molto bassa e di condizioni di vita molto dure,
e di una disciplina durissima, tenuta col bastone e con la frusta,
come in tutto il mondo di antico regime,
fare il soldato non è un mestiere prestigioso,
è il mestiere che fanno gli ultimi, che fanno i disoccupati,
che fanno i braccianti che si arruolano negli anni di cattivo raccolto,
o che fanno gli apprendisti che rimangono disoccupati quando chiude la fabbrica,
quelli sono i soldati.
Il duca di Wellington, che era di grandissima famiglia, nobile,
e uno dei capi del partito conservatore,
disse un giorno amabilmente che il suo esercito era formato dalla schiuma della terra.
Ma in Francia c'è stata la rivoluzione francese.
L'esercito francese è qualcosa di molto diverso.
L'esercito francese è il frutto dell'idea che tutti sono non sudditi, ma cittadini,
e di conseguenza devono prestare servizio per difendere la nazione quando la nazione lo chiede.
E quindi l'esercito francese è basato sulla coscrizione.
Se un soldato inglese è un poveraccio che si è arruolato volontariamente,
anche perché era disoccupato e crepava di fame,
e che presta servizio tutta la vita,
un soldato francese è un coscritto di leva.
Beninteso, non sono ancora le leve in massa degli eserciti della Prima Guerra Mondiale.
La leva veniva fatta dicendo che tutti potrebbero essere chiamati a servire,
ma all'imperatore bastano centomila uomini all'anno.
Quindi se quest'anno i giovani di leva sono trecentomila,
uno su tre presterà servizio.
E come si faceva per sapere chi avrebbe prestato servizio?
Si sorteggiava.
Notate che questo era un sistema estremamente diffuso,
è ancora il sistema con cui saranno reclutati gli eserciti del Risorgimento, per esempio.
L'esercito piemontese che combatte a Custozza e a Novara nel 1848-49 era reclutato così.
In teoria tutti sono coscritti, ma siccome non c'è bisogno di tutti, si sorteggerà.
In ogni paese i giovanotti di 18 anni un bel giorno sono convocati dal sindaco,
vanno in municipio e davanti al sindaco c'è un'urna e ognuno tira fuori il suo numero.
Quelli che tirano fuori il numero basso devono andare a fare il soldato.
C'erano anche molti modi poi per fuggire.
Se uno aveva i soldi si poteva pagare un sostituto, per esempio.
Per cui anche lì alla fine erano soprattutto i più poveri, i braccianti, i disoccupati che andavano a fare il soldato.
Ma comunque il principio, lo vedete, era radicalmente diverso.
Il principio era lo Stato ha il diritto di chiamarti e di fare di te un coscritto.
Quando Napoleone era caduto nel 1814 ed era tornato il vecchio regime,
i nuovi re che avevano ripreso il potere, i vari principi tedeschi,
il principe d'Orange che era diventato re dei Paesi Bassi,
lo stesso Luigi XVIII tornato a Parigi,
si sono trovati in una situazione politicamente imbarazzante.
Perché la coscrizione obbligatoria era il lascito più odiato della rivoluzione.
Tutti avevano promesso di abolirla.
Però era anche un bel peccato abolire una risorsa così.
Abolire una legge che permetteva al re di avere tutti gli uomini che gli servivano,
semplicemente tirando a sorte.
Questi sovrani cercano di mettere in piedi degli eserciti.
Sto parlando di quei principi tedeschi del re d'Olanda
che formano poi gran parte dell'esercito di Wellington.
Lì arriverò.
Come mai quell'esercito si sta ritirando davanti a quello di Napoleone?
Questi sovrani alla fine si riducono a un compromesso.
La leva, la coscrizione, non possiamo farla.
Perché politicamente sarebbe un suicidio.
Rifaremo un esercito di mestiere, di mercenari,
di gente che si arruola per la vita perché non sa come vivere.
Un piccolo nucleo perché costano.
E poi faremo una specie di coscrizione attenuata, la milizia.
L'idea della milizia è di grande successo nell'Europa già in precedenza,
ma poi soprattutto in quella dell'Ottocento.
L'idea che sì, il cittadino deve prestare servizio.
È un po' la Guardia Nazionale Americana, per chi conosce queste cose,
che ancora oggi esiste.
Non è proprio la leva.
Sono reparti che rimangono a casa.
La gente che fa parte di questi reparti può condurre una vita normale.
Semplicemente qualche settimana all'anno si radunano per addestrarsi un po',
e poi però quando c'è la guerra, quando c'è la guerra devono andare.
I nuovi sovrani rimessi sui loro troni dal congresso di Vienna
mettono in piedi degli eserciti basati sul principio della milizia.
Si sorteggia, ma abbastanza poca gente,
e comunque niente paura, anche se vieni sorteggiato vai solo nella milizia.
Non dovrai lasciare il lavoro, la bottega, la famiglia, i campi.
Basterà che tu faccia quelle poche settimane di addestramento all'anno.
Questo era il principio, dopodiché questi nuovi reggimenti di miliziani,
olandesi, tedeschi, sono appena stati radunati e messi in piedi,
che arriva la notizia che Napoleone ha invaso il Belgio.
E di conseguenza vengono tutti, a tutti quanti si dice,
è vero che avevamo detto che soltanto in caso di emergenza dovevate prestare servizio,
ma ecco l'emergenza.
E quindi l'esercito di Wellington è un esercito che è composto per una buona metà
da reparti reclutati in questo modo.
La differenza di qualità è enorme.
Un battaglione inglese fatto di soldati induriti, ben nutriti, bevitori di birra,
mangiatori di montone e che fanno quello di mestiere con un fortissimo senso dell'onore
e della disciplina è una cosa.
Un battaglione di milizia olandese o tedesca appena reclutato,
sorteggiando dei contadini che non ci capiscono niente,
è una cosa radicalmente diversa.
Di fronte c'è un esercito francese che è fatto tutto di coscritti,
ma sono tutti coscritti che hanno già esperienza,
Napoleone non fa in tempo a chiamare i nuovi coscritti del XV,
quindi il suo esercito è tutto formato dai vecchi coscritti del XIV, del XIII,
che hanno già combattuto.
Wellington semplicemente sa che anche se il suo esercito è fatto di 70.000 uomini,
esattamente come quello francese,
se provasse a sbarrargli la strada,
probabilmente verrebbe spazzato via.
Di conseguenza arretra.
Arretra e per tutto il giorno 17 e la notte disperatamente
manda dei corrieri ai generali prussiani
che si stanno ritirando lontano verso est
per sentire come vanno le loro cose.
Sono davvero stati sbaragliati
oppure riescono ancora a mettere insieme qualcosa e venire ad aiutarlo.
Per tutto il giorno 17 e durante la notte
si scambiano questi messaggi tra il generale inglese e i generali prussiani
che si scrivono tra loro in francese,
che è l'unica lingua internazionale che tutti conoscono,
e i prussiani gli dicono
ce la possiamo fare,
abbiamo ancora delle forze fresche,
delle forze che non sono state coinvolte nel disastro,
te le manderemo.
Se tu ti fermi a dare battaglia davanti a Bruxelles,
prima di Bruxelles,
noi ti manderemo dei soccorsi.
Anche i generali prussiani hanno discusso furiosamente per questo
perché c'era chi diceva a noi che cosa ce ne importa
di Bruxelles,
degli inglesi,
di Wellington,
non abbiamo già preso una bella batosta,
non rischiamo quello che ci rimane.
Ma alla fine prevale invece l'opinione che dice no,
è più importante che ci fermiamo anche noi
e che diamo una mano.
Di conseguenza il duca di Wellington
la sera del 17
ha la garanzia
dai prussiani
che se lui si ferma a dare battaglia
loro verranno ad aiutarlo
e questo può cambiare completamente le cose evidentemente.
Perciò decide di correre questo rischio.
Se si ritirasse ancora,
Bruxelles è lì dietro.
La perderebbe
e la stampa inglese se lo mangerebbe vivo evidentemente.
Perciò decide di dare battaglia.
Ha trovato una posizione buona,
lui è lì in Belgio da tempo,
è andato in giro a cavallo,
ha guardato i posti, le strade,
ha visto che sulla strada di Bruxelles
c'è una posizione
molto forte,
una lunga cresta,
una specie di lunga collinezza
molto bassa
che però è sufficiente
per potersi riparare dietro
a non essere quasi visti dal nemico
con alcune fattorie fortificabili,
belle robuste.
Già tempo prima
aveva detto in un appunto
se mai si dovesse dare battaglia
per difendere Bruxelles
il posto adatto è questo.
È vicino a un villaggio
che si chiama Waterloo.
Decide di fermarsi lì.
Napoleone
che lo sta inseguendo
arriva anche lui la sera
e si accorge
che il nemico
ha smesso di ritirarsi
perché si vedono
i fuochi degli inglesi
giù in fondo.
Si vede che hanno preso posizione
lungo questa cresta
e di conseguenza
Napoleone
sa che il giorno dopo
ci sarà battaglia
e dirà poi
nelle sue memorie
nessuna battaglia
mi era mai sembrata più facile
perché lui era convinto
che i prussiani
non si sarebbero più visti
e sapeva
che l'esercito di Wellington
da solo
non sarebbe stato possibile
non sarebbe stato sufficiente
per fermarlo.
Napoleone
quella notte
dorme poco
e dorme poco più che altro
perché si preoccupa
che gli inglesi
cambino idea
e se ne vadano.
Tant'è vero
che dice nelle sue memorie
a un certo punto
sono uscito
non riuscivo a dormire
da solo
con un aiutante di campo
sono andato in prima linea
e lì
ho controllato
e ho visto
giù in fondo
si continuavano a vedere
i fuochi degli inglesi
sembrava che l'orizzonte
bruciasse
come un immenso incendio
allora mi sono tranquillizzato
voleva dire
che erano ancora lì
che non se ne sarebbero andati.
E' vero che il domestico
di Napoleone
che ha scritto anche lui
le sue memorie
dice che quella notte pioveva
e l'imperatore non ha mai uscito di casa
però
però conferma
che non dormiva bene
era sveglio
si alzava
guardava dalla finestra
si tagliava le unghie
e aspettava.
Il mattino dopo
è ben chiaro
gli inglesi sono ancora lì
si preparano
a dare battaglia.
Dunque capite
qual è la situazione
se non arrivassero i prussiani
le probabilità
sono tutte a favore
di Napoleone
se i prussiani
arrivano
di colpo
i suoi nemici
diventano il doppio
e allora le cose
cambiano pesantemente.
Napoleone è convinto
che i prussiani
non arriveranno
Wellington
spera che mantengano
la promessa
e vengano.
E dunque Napoleone
prepara la battaglia
con calma
del resto è sempre stato
il suo principio
non c'è da aver fretta
si vede
come vanno le cose
si comincia
a impegnare il combattimento
su tutta la linea
mandando avanti
piccole squadre
di tiratori
che prendono contatto
col nemico
si cerca di capire bene
come è schierato il nemico
e poi
quando si vede
qual è il punto debole
lì si va dentro
con le riserve.
Perciò Napoleone
si tiene una grossa riserva
tutto il corpo
della guardia
più un altro corpo
d'armata
il sesto
sono 37 battaglioni
un terzo
del suo esercito
diciamo
capirete voi
perché vi dico
questa cifra
e il resto
lo schiera
e pian piano
manda avanti
i tiratori
per prendere contatto
aspettando di vedere
dove bisognerà dare
il colpo decisivo
se attaccare
prima con l'ala destra
o prima con l'ala sinistra
a seconda di come appare
più debole il nemico
ci pensa un po'
poi
di colpo
decide
e lì
è inspiegabile
è il colpo d'occhio
dell'uomo
che fa quel mestiere
da tanti anni
e lo ha sempre fatto
benissimo
Napoleone decide
di attaccare
sulla sua ala destra
e noi sappiamo
come facesse a saperlo
lui che non vedeva
quasi niente
c'era la cresta
che copriva il nemico
noi sappiamo che lì
Wellington era più debole
perché da quel lato
Wellington aspettava
che arrivassero i prussiani
lì aveva messo
le sue forze più deboli
quelle che erano state
già tartassate
due giorni prima
le brigate più indebolite
convinto che sarebbero
arrivati presto
i prussiani
a riempire i buchi
lì
Napoleone decide
di attaccare
e di conseguenza
il suo corpo d'armata
il primo corpo
che è schierato lì
viene mandato avanti
15.000 uomini
un corpo d'armata
quattro divisioni
otto brigate
sedici reggimenti
trentadue battaglioni
cosa vogliono dire
queste cifre
sono queste poi
le cose che troviamo
nelle storie militari
un corpo d'armata
che attacca
cosa vuol dire
vuol dire 15.000 uomini
organizzati rigidamente
che vanno avanti
come si faceva allora
come l'abbiamo visto
tante volte
nei film
ambientati nel settecento
appunto nell'epoca di Napoleone
abbiamo visto tutte queste scelte
di questa santeria
che avanza
tutti in fila
una fila dopo l'altra
al passo cadenzato
con i tamburini
che battono il passo
con il moschetto in spalla
e va avanti
verso il nemico
e il nemico
a un certo punto
comincia a sparare
la gente comincia a cadere
e tuttavia
vanno sempre avanti
così
allo scoperto
tutti in piedi
tutti in fila
tutti allo stesso passo
cadenzato
credo che tutti
se abbiamo visto
dei film del genere
ci siamo chiesti
ma è possibile
che combattessero
davvero così
e se lo facevano
perché combattevano
davvero così
ecco questa è una cosa
su cui vale la pena
di riflettere
perché questa è l'essenza
della battaglia
dell'epoca napoleonica
questi eserciti
erano fatti
per combattere così
come mai
io non so
credo che molti di voi
ci fossero già
l'altro ieri sera
a sentire raccontare
la battaglia di Campaldino
è una battaglia medievale
e io ho accennato
al fatto che
la fanteria del medioevo
non poteva fare molto
contro la cavalleria
corazzata
poteva star ferma
dietro un muro di scudi
con le lance
piantate nel terreno
sperando di resistere
se i cavalieri
gli venivano dentro
aveva un ruolo
essenzialmente passivo
le armi da fuoco
hanno cambiato tutto
ieri
molti di voi
c'erano a sentire
parlare di lei
tanto ho accennato
che la fanteria
imbarcata sulle galere
era la fanteria europea
del rinascimento
armata in parte
di archibugio
in parte di picca
corazzata ancora
con l'elmo
la corazza
una fanteria
straordinariamente
efficiente
cos'era cambiato?
era cambiato
che l'archibugio
aveva dato
per la prima volta
alla fanteria
la capacità
di aggredire
il nemico
di fargli male
di potersi muovere
e colpirlo a distanza
l'arco e le frecce
la balestra
erano dei surrogati
non avevano
la stessa valenza
l'archibugio
cambia le cose
a partire dal rinascimento
i comandanti europei
sanno che quella
è l'arma decisiva
è l'arma
tra l'altro
che vincerà
le guerre coloniali
e dunque
ci sono le armi
da fuoco
perché c'è anche
la picca
ancora
c'è ancora
la picca
perché l'unica cosa
che dei soldati
armati di archibugio
non possono fare
anche loro
è resistere
se gli viene dentro
la cavalleria
all'improvviso
se gli viene dentro
la cavalleria
l'unica cosa
è che ci sia
una massa di fanti
con delle lunghe picche
che possono
fermare
la carica
della cavalleria
dunque
nel 500
nel 600
gli eserciti europei
sono tutti fatti
di picchieri
e archibugeri
che agiscono
insieme
perché vi racconto
questo
ritorneremo sul campo
di Waterloo
e sia chiaro
vi racconto questo
perché
i comandanti
militari europei
del 500
e del 600
cominciano a riflettere
com'è che si può
rendere il più
efficiente possibile
l'uso
di queste due
armi
combinate
i picchieri
è chiaro
devono stare
tutti ammassati
perché lì sta la loro forza
un'enorme massa
di uomini
da cui si protende
come un riccio
una gran quantità
di picche
e gli archibugeri
quelli li manderemo
fuori dalla massa
ovviamente
e allora dobbiamo
un po' organizzarli
all'inizio si pensa
agli archibugeri
come a due maniche
di un abito
si dice proprio
mandiamo fuori
una manica
di archibugeri
che vengono fuori
dalla massa
si allineano tutti
sono in grado
di sparare
poi se le cose
vanno male
tornano dentro
la massa
delle picche
ma molto presto
i militari europei
si accorgono
che per ottimizzare
l'uso delle armi
da fuoco
questa straordinaria
invenzione occidentale
che sta dando
la supremazia
agli occidentali
nel mondo
per ottimizzarlo
bisogna
che gli archibugeri
lavorino tutti insieme
non più
ciascuno
per conto suo
che carica
e spara
quando vuole
è l'ufficiale
che deve dire
valutare
qual è il momento
giusto
perché cento
duecento
cinquecento archibugeri
che sparano tutti insieme
in un solo istante
hanno un fuoco
enormemente più efficace
rispetto
a quello che farebbero
se sparassero a casaccio
e allora si comincia
a ragionare
ed è incredibile
quante conseguenze
ha questa intuizione
iniziale
sulla creatività
dei militari
perché si comincia
a dire
benissimo
allora
si schierano in file
quante file
se li mettiamo
in dieci file
quelli in fondo
non potranno sparare
devono essere di meno
quattro alla fine
si dice
quattro è l'ideale
poi si dice
no no
meglio ancora
tre soltanto
gli inglesi
a un certo punto
no no
due soltanto
e si ragiona
e ci si rompe il capo
per decidere
qual è il modo migliore
per schierarli
ma poi soprattutto
bisogna insegnarli
a sparare tutti insieme
e allora si comincia
a riflettere
intanto il rinascimento
pian piano
trapassa
nell'epoca
dell'illuminismo
della ragione
nell'epoca
dell'enciclopedia
in cui si pensa
che in fondo
il mondo
è una macchina
è un ingranaggio
e tutto si può spiegare
in questo modo
e allora noi vediamo
degli intellettuali
dei militari
colti
che dicono
bene caricare
un archibugio
quanti movimenti
ci vogliono
ci sono manuali
che descrivono
60 movimenti diversi
che deve compiere
l'archibugere
per caricare
sparare
ed essere pronto
a ricaricare
e a questo punto
il passo è breve
per dire
beh insegnamoli
insegnamoli
a questi archibugieri
e a farli
tutti insieme
questi movimenti
ciascuno dovrà
imparare a fare
una sequenza
precisa di movimenti
tutti insieme
e di colpo
una compagnia
di archibugieri
diventerà
un ingranaggio
e un esercito
fatto da tante compagnie
diventerà
un meraviglioso
meccanismo
che funziona
come una macchina
agli ordini
dei suoi comandanti
è un'illusione
come vedete
che non tiene conto
di tanti fattori
il fattore umano
la paura
il caos
ma è un'illusione
profondamente radicata
nella cultura europea
dal seicento in poi
l'illusione
che gli uomini
possono essere trattati
come macchine
tanto lo sappiamo
sono tutti miserabili mercenari
poveracci
analfabeti
di conseguenza
è chiaro
che i loro comandanti
devono tenerli in pugno
come se fossero
appunto
ingranaggi
e allora
non soltanto sparare
devono farlo tutti insieme
anche muoversi
marciare tutti insieme
ai soldati
cosa insegneremo
per prima cosa
a mettersi in fila
e poi a marciare
al passo
un due
lo si inventa
in quell'epoca
gli antichi romani
non le facevano mica
queste cose
anche se i legionari
nei fumetti di Asterix
lo fanno
ma in realtà
è un'invenzione europea
di quest'epoca
che riflette
questo sogno
dei generali
di avere degli eserciti
che possono essere
manovrati
come meccanismi
e allora si inventa
il concetto
dell'addestramento
al soldato
si deve insegnare
a eseguire
tutta una serie
di movimenti
lui neanche deve sapere
che lo sta facendo
quando sente
l'ordine del comandante
deve fare quel movimento lì
e il risultato
sarà appunto
la perfezione
tutto il settecento
insegue questa perfezione
degli eserciti
spersonalizzati
dove gli uomini
si muovono come macchine
e ancora
all'epoca di Napoleone
gran parte di questo
è rimasto
per carità
come sapete
è rimasto ancora oggi
nel senso che
l'idea che innanzitutto
ai soldati si deve insegnare
a marciare
un due
perché questo crea
la disciplina
e l'organizzazione
è una cosa che
ancora oggi
in qualche modo
gli eserciti si portano dietro
ma all'epoca
quello era il modo migliore
per farli combattere
anziché
non lasciare nulla
all'improvvisazione
lasciare che il genio
del comandante
potesse usare
appunto l'esercito
come uno strumento
senza volontà
a sua disposizione
e dunque
le masse
che Napoleone
manda all'attacco
contro la linea
di Wellington
nel punto
più debole
che lui miracolosamente
ha indovinato
là dietro la cresta
sono masse
che avanzano
in questo modo
avanzano in questo modo
sono stati addestrati
questi soldati
ad avanzare così
a obbedire ciecamente
agli ordini
dei loro ufficiali
gli ufficiali
anche loro
sono stati addestrati
devono conoscere
tutti gli ordini
e gli ordini giusti
che ordini devo dare
se i miei soldati
che sono tutti in fila
si devono mettere
di colpo
inquadrato
per difendersi
dalla cavalleria
e quindi essere in grado
di avere
dei moschetti
che sparano a tutte le parti
devo conoscere
gli ordini
precisi
se li sbaglio
i soldati
cominceranno a fare
dei movimenti insensati
e sarà il caos
anche qui
lo sforzo
l'illusione
di poter trasformare
la guerra
in un'attività
interamente
razionale
siamo veramente
alla fine
dell'illuminismo europeo
al vertice
e dunque
questa fanteria
avanza
15.000 uomini
tutti su file regolari
tutti col moschetto
in spalla
che avanzano
contro il nemico
e il nemico
gli spara
con i cannoni
che sono lontani
perché i moschetti
di quest'epoca
che hanno sostituito
gli archibugi
hanno perfezionato
i moschetti
sparano a 100 metri
più in là
non servono
praticamente
quindi per buona parte
della loro marcia
verso il nemico
questi soldati
vanno avanti
e ogni tanto
arriva una palla di cannone
che vola in mezzo a loro
non esplode
perché non ci sono ancora
le granate esplosive
o sono comunque molto rare
normalmente la palla di cannone
è una palla
che vola
ad altezza d'uomo
e che se investe
una fila di uomini
è in grado di ammazzare
il primo
il secondo
il terzo
il quarto
anche il quinto
magari
ecco
e tutti vanno avanti
sperando di non essere loro
quelli che prenderanno la palla
ma i generali sanno
che è meglio così
piuttosto che lasciarli andare avanti
ciascuno per conto suo
riparandosi
non è così
che si può fare la guerra
bisogna rischiare
sapere
che l'1%
saranno uccisi
di sicuro
se va male il 5%
se va malissimo il 10%
non importa
avete presente
l'espressione
carne da cannone
ecco
questo vuol dire
la carne da cannone
vuol dire
che i generali sanno
che
perderanno
una parte
dei loro uomini
ma non importa
tutto l'esercito
è stato costruito
perché quegli uomini
sappiano che devono
lo stesso andare avanti
che l'onore lo impone
se sono veri uomini
lo devono fare
in ogni caso
se disertano
finiranno molto male
perciò
sono stati addestrati
e non hanno altro da fare
che andare avanti
questo attacco
di Napoleone
avrebbe potuto
concludere
la battaglia di Waterloo
e in effetti
la linea inglese
di fronte a loro
stava già sfaldandosi
vedendogli arrivare
quando succede
il caso
Wellington aveva
un'unica riserva
in quella zona
una divisione di cavalleria
un migliaio
di cavalleggeri
li manda dentro
c'è questa collinetta
per cui i francesi
che stanno andando avanti
non si rendono conto
di quello che succede
avanzano tutti in fila
intravedono appena
la fanteria inglese
davanti a loro
che sta arretrando
appena arrivano
in cima
a questa collinetta
di colpo
si vedono di fronte
un migliaio di cavalieri
con le sciabole sguainate
che gli stanno venendo incontro
non stanno caricando
al galoppo
come si vede nei quadri
perché il terreno
era irregolare
stavano risalendo
un pendio
gli inglesi
e poi comunque
non si caricava quasi mai
al galoppo
perché i cavalli
dopo pochi minuti
al galoppo
non ce la fanno più
e il pericolo maggiore
era che i cavalli
alla fine
spompati
diventassero inutili
stavano venendo avanti
quasi al passo
ci dicono le testimonianze
e tuttavia
la fanteria francese
che fino a quel momento
è andata avanti
sotto il fuoco
vedendo morire la gente
quando arrivava la palla di cannone
negli ultimi cento metri
anche sotto il fuoco
dei moschetti
in mezzo al fumo
e che tuttavia
è andata avanti
perché il suo addestramento
la forzava
ad andare avanti
e i tamburi rullavano
e quindi rullavano
ossessivamente
e la gente aveva imparato
ad andare avanti
a passo cadenzato
e andava avanti
in massa
tutti insieme
io col compagno di qua
e col compagno di là
gli altri dietro
gli altri davanti
e gli ufficiali
che gridavano
viva l'imperatore
e l'imperatore
ricompenserà
quello che arriverà
sulle linee nemiche
per primo
tutta questa gente
che è andata avanti
e che sente la vittoria
già in mano
vedendosi arrivare addosso
questa marea
di gente a cavallo
con le sciabole sguainate
di colpo
viene presa dal panico
e comincia a retrare
a rinculare
e poi a scappare
disperatamente
tutta questa massa
di fanteria
15.000 uomini
fugge
a rotta di collo
inseguita
dalla cavalleria inglese
che ovviamente
sciabola
e abbatte
ed è come dire
come se
per Napoleone
fosse necessario
in questo momento
ricordarsi
che appunto
la razionalità
non è tutto
gli eserciti
non sono ingranaggi
sono pur sempre
fatti di esseri umani
che hanno
emozioni
passioni
l'addestramento
cerca di fargliene
dimenticare
ma poi in realtà
in battaglia
quello che succede
invece è proprio questo
che la gente
all'improvviso
si rende conto
di quello che sta succedendo
che sta rischiando
la pelle
mentre tutto
l'addestramento
cerca di fartelo
dimenticare
quando te ne rendi conto
è il panico
e così Napoleone
è al punto di partenza
la sua offensiva
è stata fermata
non si scoraggia
c'è ancora tanto tempo
i prussiani
ancora non si vedono
lui è ancora
molte forze intatte
ha ancora la sua famosa
riserva di 37 battaglioni
pronta
al centro
si tratta soltanto
di trovare
un altro punto debole
nello schieramento nemico
manda avanti
la sua cavalleria
a vedere cosa si può fare
e di fronte
all'arrivo
della cavalleria francese
gli inglesi
dietro la loro cresta
abbandonano i loro cannoni
perché sarebbe impossibile
pensare di difenderli
se la cavalleria
ci arriva in mezzo
e si formano
ciascun battaglione
si forma in quadrato
è quella formazione
che accennavo prima
quando anziché
presentare una fronte
al nemico
si fa appunto
un quadrato
in modo che da ogni lato
c'è una selva
di moschetti
e di baionette
che permettono
di resistere
alla cavalleria
la baionette
è il motivo
per cui non si usa più
la picca
come si usava nel seicento
perché adesso
lo stesso uomo
che spara
ha anche
una lunga punta
di lancia
che gli permette
di tenere lontana
la cavalleria nemica
si formano
questi quadrati
e questa fase
della battaglia di Waterloo
è una delle fasi
più surreali
perché i francesi
un'altra volta
hanno l'impressione
di aver vinto
la loro cavalleria
ha preso
i cannoni inglesi
la fanteria inglese
è lì
inglese
tedesca
olandese
è lì dietro
immobilizzata
in quadrato
tutti i generali
inglesi
sono dentro
i quadrati
Wellington
è dentro
uno dei quadrati
se quei 7-800 uomini
che ha intorno
si spaventassero
e scappassero
verrebbero fatti fuori
tutti dai corazzieri
francesi
lui compreso
ordini
non ne possono dare
ma la cavalleria
non va dentro
i quadrati
perché il quadrato
è una formazione
che è fatta apposta
perché la cavalleria
non la possa attaccare
non perché i cavalieri
non vorrebbero
magari vorrebbero anche
i loro ufficiali
vorrebbero
sono i cavalli
che non vogliono
i cavalli
non vanno
contro un muro
di punte d'acciaio
non vanno
contro i quadrati
molte descrizioni
sono chiarissime
i corazzieri
arrivavano
veloci
rallentavano
e poi i cavalli
stessi
schiumanti
si fermavano
a pochi metri
dalle punte
delle baionette
e vanno avanti
per parte del pomeriggio
a fare questo gioco
micidiale
i corazzieri
sono lì
in mezzo ai quadrati
Wellington dice
c'erano dei momenti
in cui la cavalleria nemica
passeggiava in mezzo a noi
come se fosse stata
la nostra
dai quadrati
non sparano
perché una delle cose
che insegnano agli ufficiali
è non farli sparare
quando sono inquadrato
perché se sparano
si crea disordine
non faranno niente
perché tanto hanno paura
spareranno alto
e i corazzieri nemici
se vedono che quelli
hanno sparato
prendono coraggio
e allora non si sa
cosa può succedere
perciò i fanti
nei quadrati
non sparano
e i corazzieri
non possono andargli dentro
e aspettano di vedere
ci sono infiniti
piccoli duelli
giocati
tra gli ufficiali inglesi
che cercano di tenere
in piedi
in mano
i loro uomini
dicendo
niente panico
state fermi
perché se state fermi
è l'unico modo
di salvarsi
se qualcuno
comincia a scappare
siamo finiti
e gli ufficiali
dei corazzieri
francesi
che girano
intorno a questi
quadrati
per vedere
se c'è qualche
quadrato
magari di reclute
della milizia
che comincia
a prendersi paura
perché se si vede
che si prendono paura
che cominciano
un po'
oscillare alle baionette
allora magari
si fa venire avanti
uno squadrone
di corazzieri
che fanno la faccia
feroce
e chissà
che quelli
non comincino a scappare
e qui il ruolo
degli ufficiali
è decisivo
e questo è l'altro aspetto
su cui vorrei fermarmi
un momento
prima di continuare
il racconto
di questa battaglia
gli ufficiali
di questi eserciti
chi sono?
abbiamo detto
che l'esercito inglese
e quello francese
sono diversissimi
un esercito di mestiere
di antico regime
quello inglese
un esercito
di coscritti
moderno quindi
diremmo noi
quello di Napoleone
anche gli ufficiali
il discorso è lo stesso
nell'antico regime
come si diventava ufficiali
bisognava essere
se possibile nobili
se no comunque
ben raccomandati
con buone aderenze
dopodiché
in via del tutto privata
si veniva presentati
a un colonnello
il quale diceva
va bene
ho un posto libero
ti prendo nel mio reggimento
quando certi governi
di antico regime
si erano accorti
che i colonnelli
si facevano pagare
per prendere
nel loro reggimento
qualche giovanotto
di buona famiglia
i governi hanno pensato
forse potremmo farci pagare
noi tutto sommato
e di conseguenza
in particolare
in Inghilterra
il governo
di sua maestà
aveva cominciato
a vendere
i posti da ufficiale
nei reggimenti
e i nobili
li compravano
e anche i figli
quando andava bene
dell'industriale
del ricco negoziante
ma molti nobili
il duca di Wellington
aveva seguito
questa trafila
era diventato colonnello
senza aver mai combattuto
una battaglia
semplicemente
comprando un posto
da sottotenente
molto giovane
poi uno da tenente
sei mesi dopo
uno da capitano
due o tre anni dopo
era di buona famiglia
aveva buona aderenza
molti soldi
e in questo modo
si facevano gli ufficiali
nell'esercito inglese
voi capite
che se la massa
dei soldati
è fatta
di disperati
che ci sono arruolati
perché non avevano lavoro
e gli ufficiali
sono gente
della buona società
che ha comprato
il suo grado
non c'è comunicazione
possibile
che non sia il linguaggio
del dare ordini
e dell'ubbidire
cominciamo a capire
perché l'esercito inglese
è stato l'ultimo
tra quelli europei
che ha abolito
le punizioni corporali
nell'esercito di Napoleone
un coscritto
non poteva essere
attaccato a quattro pioli
e frustato
nell'esercito inglese
sì
e questo avveniva regolarmente
detto per parentesi
subito prima di Vatterlo
ci sono testimonianze
dal Belgio
di autorità locali
belghe
che si rivolgono
ai generali inglesi
dicendo
per favore smettete
con queste punizioni corporali
ai vostri soldati
perché la gente
si scandalizza un po'
perché sul continente
non si usa più
ecco
e nell'esercito francese
che era un esercito moderno
uscito dalla rivoluzione
la grande maggioranza
degli ufficiali
erano soldati
che erano stati promossi
perché avevano dimostrato
valore, bravura
competenza
ed erano stati promossi
vedete
non si potrebbe immaginare
una differenza maggiore
da una parte
un esercito
che riflette esattamente
la struttura privilegiata
ferocemente privilegiata
e gerarchica
del mondo vecchio
di antico regime
dall'altra
un esercito
che riflette
i valori nuovi
l'eguaglianza
la mobilità sociale
ogni soldato
si diceva
ha nello zaino
il bastone da maresciallo
pochissimi diventavano
marescialli di Francia
ma molti diventavano ufficiali
la statistica dice
più o meno
i tre quarti
degli ufficiali
che hanno servito
sotto Napoleone
hanno cominciato
sotto soldati semplici
come soldati semplici
volevo dire
dopodiché
io vi dico questo
perché secondo me
ci sono tante
le considerazioni
che vengono fuori
da questo discorso
per esempio
come sarebbe consolante
fare lo storico
se fosse l'esercito moderno
che ha vinto
la battaglia di Waterloo
invece non è così
è l'esercito arcaico
che rifletteva
un mondo
superato
quello che ha vinto
l'esercito francese
è stato sconfitto
e
in quella situazione
con quei quadrati
di gente
che doveva essere tenuta
saldamente in pugno
dai suoi ufficiali
c'è da chiedersi
se non era migliore
il sistema inglese
per cui i soldati
guardavano all'ufficiale
come a un signore
a un gentiluomo
un uomo che naturalmente
aveva il diritto
di comandare
e che aveva anche
il diritto
di fargli somministrare
300 frustate
se per caso
sgarravano
la disciplina di ferro
ha permesso
ai quadrati inglesi
di tenere duro
in quella situazione
mentre
molte testimonianze
ci dicono
che l'esercito
di Napoleone
a Waterloo
era un bellissimo esercito
fatto tutto
di veterani
gente molto motivata
ma anche
indisciplinata
caotica
disubbidiente
preoccupata
gente che sospettava
gli ufficiali
di essere dei traditori
un esercito
dove serpeggiava
il dissenso politico
c'era chi in segreto
stava con i borboni
in realtà
e i soldati
non rispettavano
i loro ufficiali
come avrebbero dovuto
rispettarli
fatto sta
che la cavalleria francese
non riesce a sfondare
i quadrati
e si logora
nel fare
questa attività
questi tentativi
continui
di superarli
ogni tanto
un piccolo combattimento
gli sparano
si stancano
i cavalli
alla fine
non è così
che Napoleone
sfonderà
e mentre
Napoleone
è lì
che si chiede
da che parte
dopo tutto
dovrà gettare
la sua grande riserva
per sfondare
visto che non sia ancora
così tanto chiarita
la situazione
e mentre
Wellington
è lì che si chiede
ma arriveranno
i prussiani
finalmente
perché
Wellington
sa di essere appeso
a un filo
perché finora
sta tenendo
ma non è chiaro
quanto tempo
ancora potrà tenere
ebbene
i prussiani
a un certo punto
arrivano
spuntano
le prime colonne
prussiane
sul fianco
dell'esercito
di Napoleone
è uno dei paradossi
e che Wellington
non se ne accorge
perché lui
se li aspettava
molto più vicini
che venissero
a riempire i vuoti
nel suo schieramento
invece i prussiani
hanno fatto
un'altra strada
e sono spuntati
quasi alle spalle
di Napoleone
una cosa enormemente
più utile
fra l'altro
perché minacciano
di prendere
sul fianco
e alle spalle
l'esercito
di Napoleone
e quando Napoleone
se ne accorge
sono già molto vicini
è una zona
di foreste
di boschi
quella
questi sbucano
dalla boscaglia
e ci sono resoconti
dei generali prussiani
che dicono
e noi da lì
vedevamo
le sentinelle francesi
guardavano tutte
dall'altra parte
e noi siamo
andati avanti
quando Napoleone
se ne accorge
non può fare
nient'altro
se non prendere
una parte
delle sue riserve
e mandarle
a fronteggiare
i prussiani
aveva questi benedetti
37 battaglioni
una massa sufficiente
per sfondare
il fronte
di Wellington
ancora in questo momento
però ci sono i prussiani
che stanno venendo avanti
perciò
prende
il corpo d'armata
di Mutton
il sesto corpo
15 battaglioni
e li manda
a fronteggiare
i prussiani
e lui intanto
continua
a tastare
il terreno
a cercare
di far cadere
le posizioni
più avanzate
degli inglesi
per farsi spazio
e lanciare finalmente
la carica finale
i prussiani
vengono avanti
i 15 battaglioni francesi
sono pochi
sono buoni
sono migliori
i prussiani
sono coscritti
freschi freschi
che non sanno combattere
tanto bene
ancora
subiscono gravissime perdite
però
sono animati
da un odio fanatico
per i francesi
vengono avanti
lo stesso
i 15 battaglioni francesi
vengono lentamente
respinti
fino a un grosso villaggio
che si chiama
Plin-Sainois
che è praticamente
alle spalle
dello schieramento francese
e lì
si trincerano
si logorano
e a un certo punto
a Napoleone
vengono a dire
guarda che Plin-Sainois
sta cadendo
e i cannoni
prussiani
sono ormai
così avanti
che le loro palle
cadono
sulla posizione
da dove Napoleone
col cannocchiale
sta guardando
il fronte
e di fronte a Wellington
come sta andando?
sta andando bene
i francesi
conquistano delle posizioni
c'è una grande
fattoria fortificata
la Essent
proprio in mezzo
allo schieramento
e i francesi
la stanno prendendo
se la prendono
poi c'è lo spazio
aperto
lì si potrà lanciare
la grande carica
della riserva
e sfondare
il fronte di Wellington
però intanto
i prussiani
stanno arrivando
Napoleone
cosa ha ancora
di riserva?
aveva 37 battaglioni
15 li ha usati
gliene restano 22
la guardia
prende i peggiori
la giovane guardia
8 battaglioni
li manda
a Plin-Sainois
e la giovane guardia
arriva
riconquista
Plin-Sainois
sbatte fuori
i prussiani
e tiene duro
e intanto
i francesi
conquistano
la fattoria
al centro
dello schieramento
e di colpo
hanno di fronte
le posizioni nemiche
ormai
in vista
hanno conquistato
la cresta
gli inglesi sono dietro
in vista
pronti per la mazzata
finale
ma intanto
i prussiani
stanno insistendo
ostinatamente
a costo di perdite
terrificanti
Wellington
non lo sa neanche
che loro sono già lì
e stanno combattendo
continua a guardare
l'orologio
e a chiedersi
ma perché non arrivano
maledetti crucchi
tuttavia loro sono lì
stanno combattendo
da ore
molto lontano
dietro lo schieramento
di Napoleone
anche la giovane guardia
si consuma
in questa fornace
di questo villaggio
che ormai è in rovina
e brucia
e i prussiani
ormai stanno
uscendo fuori
da questo villaggio
Napoleone
fa una cosa
che non avrebbe voluto fare
37 battaglioni all'inizio
15 già mandati
più 8 della giovane guardia
ma già mandati 23
gli restano 14
anzi 13
perché uno
l'ha tenuto indietro
col suo tesoro
e con le sue carrozze
e i suoi cavalli
perché non si sa mai
quanti ne può sacrificare
per fermare ancora i prussiani
due
molto malvolentieri
due dei migliori
i granatieri
e i cacciatori
della vecchia guardia
i soldati migliori del mondo
un migliaio di uomini
in tutto
non di più
dentro Plansenois
ci saranno 10.000 prussiani
i due battaglioni
della giovane guardia
della vecchia guardia
vengono mandati a Plansenois
caricano la baionetta
spazzano via
tutto quello che si trovano davanti
riconquistano il villaggio
ricacciano i prussiani
in fuga
in una tale orgia di violenza
che i loro comandanti
devono impedirgli
di sgozzare i prigionieri
come avevano cominciato a fare
d'altra parte
anche i prussiani
baionettavano regolarmente
i feriti francesi
talmente forte
era l'odio
che le lunghe guerre napoleoniche
avevano provocato
tra prussiani
e francesi
dunque
l'offensiva prussiana
è di nuovo
al punto di partenza
sono le 7 di sera
hanno subito perdite
terrificanti
non sono riusciti
a sbucare fuori
da questo maledetto villaggio
però a Napoleone
restano solo 11 battaglioni
per l'attacco finale
lui aveva calcolato
di farlo con 37
vedete voi
gliene restano 11
manda avanti
i suoi cannoni
a sparare
le ultime munizioni
contro la fila
dei quadrati inglesi
e lì tutte le testimonianze
dalla parte inglese
ci dicono
è stato il momento
più terrificante
perché i cannoni francesi
venivano a 300 metri
e tiravano a mitraglia
è il momento
in cui intorno a Wellington
cadono uno dopo l'altro
i suoi aiutanti di campo
i suoi amici
lui rimane illeso
miracolosamente
dirà poi
il dito di Dio
è stato su di me
perché intorno a lui
sono morti quasi tutti
morti o feriti
quasi tutti
è il momento
in cui qualche battaglione
dell'esercito di Wellington
comincia davvero
a sfasciarsi
perché quando ti arrivano
i cannoni a 300 metri
e cominciano a tirare
a mitraglia
neanche più la disciplina
in partita col bastone
può tenere fermi
gli uomini
dopodiché
i cannoni inglesi
finiscono le munizioni
i cannoni francesi
scusate
bisogna mandar dentro
la riserva
la guardia
e Napoleone
manda dentro
la guardia
quello che gli resta
quegli undici battaglioni
che gli restano
la guardia va avanti
i prussiani
hanno ricominciato
ad attaccare
a Plan Senua
ma per il momento
ancora
quelli che sono lì
tengono duro
ma l'attacco finale
contro la linea
di Wellington
che avrebbe dovuto
essere fatto
da più di 30 battaglioni
viene fatto
con un terzo
delle forze
che si era previsto
di usare
e a quel punto
questo attacco
nonostante
la fama mondiale
della guardia
nonostante il fatto
che questi
siano davvero
i migliori soldati
del mondo
però hanno di fronte
un avversario
degno di loro
e questo attacco
lo sanno tutti
fallisce
l'ultimo attacco
della vecchia guardia
fallisce
la guardia va avanti
anche loro
in formazione serrata
come gli hanno insegnato
con i moschetti
in spalla
va avanti
sotto il fuoco
dei cannoni
Wellington
butta avanti
tutto quello che ha
tutta la fanteria
inglese
che gli resta
perché quella
olandese
tedesca
ormai
emidizia
sono così stanchi
ragazzi
sono così logori
che non è il caso
di metterli avanti
manda avanti
tutti gli inglesi
che gli restano
che almeno sono soldati
veri
veterani
e questi
con il loro fuoco
fermano
i francesi
i loro ufficiali
ci dicono
li vedevamo avanzare
e sembrava letteralmente
come una massa
che si squagliava
colpita dal vento
avanzano
finché possono
poi non ce la fanno più
stanno ancora fermi
un po' ostinatamente
e poi cosa devono fare
cominciano ad andare indietro
e in tutto
l'esercito francese
quando ci si accorge
che la guardia
arretra
si decide
che tutto sommato
peccato
era bello
ma non ce l'abbiamo fatta
è inutile
domani un altro giorno
si torna a casa
l'intero esercito francese
vedendo fallire
questo attacco
decide
che è inutile
continuare
tutto sommato
ci tenevano tanto
all'imperatore
ma
non si può
pretendere troppo
dall'uomo
l'intero esercito francese
comincia a ritirarsi
è una ritirata
relativamente ordinata
sia chiaro
quasi nessun reggimento
perde le sue bandiere
le sue aquile
però pian piano
si sfaldano
perché sempre più gente
dice
io per conto mio
ho finito
torno a casa
due o tre giorni dopo
i generali di Napoleone
riescono a radunare
quel che resta
in Francia
e sono rimasti
più o meno
metà dell'esercito
non di più
non sono tutti morti
o feriti
o prigionieri
tantissimi
se ne sono andati
a casa
e questa è la battaglia
di Waterloo
dopodiché
naturalmente
che cosa succede
succede che si comincia
a scrivere le memorie
e lì si che la creatività
si esercita
Napoleone scrive
delle straordinarie memorie
che sono come fonte storica
sostanzialmente inutili
perché mente spudoratamente
dappertutto
e dice
non è assolutamente colpa mia
io avevo dato ordine
a Grouchy
il comandante
dell'ala destra
di raggiungermi a Waterloo
se lui fosse venuto
prenderanno in trappola
i prussiani
e li avremmo sterminati
in realtà
se uno guarda
come fanno gli storici
come ho fatto anch'io
sulle cartine
calcola le distanze
i tempi
gli ordini di Napoleone
erano irrealizzabili
le sue forze
dell'ala destra
non avrebbero mai potuto
venire
in tempo
sul campo di Waterloo
ma lui ha scritto questo
e questa è una delle versioni
che sono passate alla storia
la storiografia inglese
che è assolutamente
dominante
in quest'ambito
e che è riuscita
in sostanza
a far passare
questa battaglia
come la vittoria inglese
facendo dimenticare
che c'erano gli olandesi
i belgi
i prussiani
e così via
la storiografia inglese
in sostanza dice
noi abbiamo tenuto duro
la fanteria inglese
è la migliore del mondo
i francesi
sono venuti dentro
gli inglesi
li hanno aspettati
i francesi
si sa
sono gente continentale
emotiva
latini
rumorosi
indisciplinati
la fanteria inglese
è la migliore del mondo
stava ferma
immobile
in silenzio
e li ha respinti
col suo fuoco superiore
e gli inglesi
hanno vinto la battaglia
il problema è che
la storiografia inglese
ha faticato
a rendersi conto
che per ore e ore
durante quella giornata
i prussiani
molto lontano di lì
dietro le linee di Napoleone
laddove gli inglesi
non li vedevano neanche
non sapevano che c'erano
per ore e ore
i prussiani
si sono logorati
e hanno sacrificato
migliaia di uomini
e hanno ottenuto
il risultato decisivo
hanno consumato
la riserva di Napoleone
se i prussiani
non fossero venuti dentro
e Napoleone
avesse potuto attaccare
con trenta battaglioni
e non con undici
avrebbe senza nessun dubbio
sfondato
la linea di Wellington
e la battaglia di Waterloo
sarebbe andata a finire
in un altro modo
fatto sta
che la storiografia tedesca
ha perso
la guerra degli storici
nell'ottocento
ha provato
a scrivere libri
dove si diceva
siamo noi
che abbiamo vinto
poi sapete
il novecento
è andato come è andato
la storiografia militare tedesca
tutto sommato
ha perso
un po' di ragion d'essere
e ufficialmente
appunto
tutti sanno
e io stesso
io stesso vi ho raccontato
degli inglesi
vedete com'è difficile
uscire dagli stereotipi
io stesso vi dicevo
l'esercito inglese
i quadrati
di quei quadrati
appunto
la maggior parte
erano fatti
di ragazzotti
olandesi
belgi
tedeschi
reclutati nella milizia
all'ultimo momento
e che i loro ufficiali
nobili
hanno saputo tenere fermi
e non farli scappare
però davanti agli occhi
ci sono sempre gli inglesi
questa è la battaglia
di Waterloo
io ho voluto
non soltanto raccontarvi
la battaglia
ma anche cercare
di dare qualche
squarcio
su come erano fatti
questi eserciti
e su come
riflettevano
le contraddizioni
della società
del tempo
la contraddizione
più forte
in assoluto
da cui appunto
non riesco a uscirne
vedete ve lo dico
ancora una volta
è il fatto che il paese
che da un lato
stava facendo la rivoluzione
industriale
l'Inghilterra
avesse un esercito
così arcaico
che rifletteva
valori così superati
credo che ci sia
una lezione
da ricavare da questo
non so bene
però quale sia
in ogni caso
non lo troveremo
credo noi
qui stasera
mi dicono
che diversamente
dalle altre sere
noi potremmo
avere il tempo
qui
dato che non ci sono
altri eventi
che incombono
per avere
qualche domanda
dal pubblico
a cui rispondere
così pubblicamente
anziché raccoglierci
in un crocchio
come abbiamo fatto
le altre sere
detto questo
però
vediamo
se questo succederà
ma
non vorrei comunque
privarci di una conclusione
ufficiale
della lezione
e quindi direi
grazie
never minute
Grazie.